all right
i'm gonna get started this is lecture 23
uh
about policy with the evil agent uh the
last lecture of 14
uh 13 for better or worse um
okay so what's the plan for today we're
going to talk about
paternalism what is paternalism reasons
for paternalism uh
why it might be popular or or not
we're going to talk about a specific
example of uh
what was coined as uh libertarian
paternalism i'll explain more which is
to save more tomorrow plan what's good
about this
specific example and we'll discuss that
and finally
we'll talk about market solutions often
it's sort of
one solution that's all conventions to
say well why can't the market
solve these kinds of issues and we're
going to talk about uh why that may or
may not be a good idea
okay so then let me just ask very simply
to start
with um from your classes if you're
taking in economics and otherwise
what are some reasons for government
policies
um you know and doesn't mean that he
necessarily endorse those reasons but
what are reasons why the government
why we might want the government to
engage in in
uh economic or other sort of government
policies
yes so one uh reason might be that
people don't quite know um
what's good for them and so we can
potentially help them
by doing so that's of course the reason
uh uh that's of course we're gonna talk
about
today let me rephrase my question um
in neoclassical economics what are
reasons for the government
to engage so the behavioral ones are of
course what we're going to call like
internalities which is essentially
people misoptimize in certain ways
but one of the neoclassical reasons to
for the government to to
engage so like this would be things like
um
externalities this could be individuals
uh causing externalities
externalities essentially is a fancy
word for like
people causing some positive or negative
effects on others that they might not be
able to
internalize this could be smokers or
individuals doing that
uh like for example smoking you might
cause health effects on others
uh could be also farms polluting the
environment or polluting sort of like um
water or some other sources of other
people polluting
in otherwise the air and so on and so
forth which might be bad for others
health
and to the extent that the firm or
others are not sort of taking
that into account that'll lead to
socially um suboptimal outcomes now the
government would say well
let's tax that because we want to make
sure that people are
taking into account these these uh
externalities and with the optimal tax
schedule potentially at least you can
get back to the first faster so some
at least you can improve off potentially
so usually the the theorems about like
free markets etc
they essentially will the free market
will achieve that things are efficient
or potentially under some conditions
but what the market will not typically
achieve
is sort of some form of equity and sort
of to the extent that we
are interested in that you might want to
engage in social security insurance
program unemployment insurance
and so on and so forth so if you have
lots of competition
the prices will fall down to often
marginal costs and that's good for
consumers because stuff is cheap
he could only one firm the firm the
monopolist in the most stuck
in case the monopolist will charge above
um a marginal cost
so prices will be higher fewer things
will be sold and people will be
um less happy about that and sort of
then there's sort of this
the anti-trust in 1420 as you say
exactly nancy rose and others are
working on that uh and their trust
commissions et cetera
china essentially make sure uh there's
sufficient competition in markets
because do you think that's good for
welfare
so there's uh other sort of market
failures for example
um public goods um uh parks and so on
the government might want to provide
that because in general people might
under under um provide that
could be also other things like
information markets for information tend
to fail the reason being that
uh uh when i come up with an idea that's
is useful for a lot of people i might
not be able to internalize the rents
from that
instead of i'm under investing therefore
in
r d and so on so now i think we have all
all the things i have on my list as
macroeconomic policy as can just mention
the federal reserve might
be uh that's interest rate there might
be fiscal stimulus
competition policy that's what everyone
just mentioned then there's just
redistribution social insurance i think
that's what um
justin said on employment insurance
social security and so on
and then there might be uh externality
that's what natalie said um
uh uh cigarette taxes and other sort of
market failures
such as uh innovation that's um what
uh jose uh as well said what we're gonna
focus on now is
none of these things which uh and that's
getting back to what we said um at the
very beginning which is
internalities so that's a not a
traditional way for governments to
to engage in if you went back like 20
years from now the government that there
would be no such
very few such considerations but more
recently
in part perhaps because as a consequence
of the rise of people economics
people are much more interested now in
uh internalities and what are
internalities
it's essentially sort of similar to to
accenture
the coin is very similar uh instead of
um
causing damage or not um internalizing
sufficiently uh effects on other people
this is now effects on
your future self essentially and so the
kotoma does not fully or properly
internalize all the costs and or
benefits
she imposes on her uh future potential
um itself
and if the government is sort of not
confident that that's the case well then
the government might want to
to intervene now what's paternalism but
journalism is essentially
um a version of that there's a very
convoluted um
definition by the american webster um
dictionary which i'm not going to read
to you but it's you know at least one
definition and
there's a better one from david lipson
um which is an attempt to influence or
control uh people's conduct
for their own good in other words when
the motivation for the intervention is
not about
externalities so it's to say if we try
to affect people's behavior for their
own good in some ways and that sort of
assumes of course
that people are not fully optimizing in
certain ways
not when it comes to like their effects
on others but
rather the effects on themselves
okay so there is a question
now when is um
paternalism warm that we can sort of go
through the list of
um topics that we discussed in the class
and it's important to understand that
like not all of these topics
are in fact warranting intervention for
example if you think people have certain
risk preferences
reference dependent preferences or
social preferences that's not a bias or
problem that we need to fix people care
about
others and that's just the way their
utility function is like
and then you kind of make sure that
people can optimize
their uh optimize accordingly
that's not necessarily a bias or a
problem
of course if there's problems with
self-control problems where people are
timing consistent preferences we might
want to sort of help people
that assumes of course that we know
which self is the one we want to
to support uh there's lots of
space here when you think about
non-standard beliefs for people to uh
make mistakes so for our governments and
others to intervene
this would be limited attention also
things like memory where people just
forget stuff
um learning failures people just have
wrong information over optimism over
confidence
projection and attribution bias these
are all essentially people that make
mistakes in some ways
and to the extent that they make these
mistakes we might want to intervene
importantly we discussed this already
motivated beliefs
are not necessarily a reason or want to
be very careful with that
that is as we said previously when we
talked about health issues for example
so if somebody
does not want to know their health
status because they want to feel happy
or make themselves
think that they're happy and they don't
want to know that
uh because you know they want to have a
few years of their lives in which they
think you know can we loot themselves
and thinking they're happy
they're healthy and happy um it's not
obvious
that they're making a mistake in a sense
they could be making a mistake because
potentially there could be health
investments or health behaviors that
they could engage in to improve their
behavior
but it could also just be that look
there's actually not much one can do
and so now there's if you intervene we
might actually make things worse
because there's somebody who actually
doesn't even want to know um what's
going on that's
often that's actually the case but i'm
sort of just flagging that for motivated
beliefs
when people derive utility from beliefs
things get
tricky quite easily let me talk about
non-standard decision-making gender
discrimination there's a clear case for
for intervention that people don't get
treated the right way
as they should or any other
discrimination
um and then we talked about these other
um aspects here of course then default
frames and not just are not sort of
necessarily reasons to intervene these
are more like
instruments that we can use to intervene
you can sort of set defaults or frames
or not just in certain ways that help us
to make people make different choices in
ways that are potentially
fairly cheap and then also in ways that
don't really necessarily distort
behaviors of everyone i'm going to get
back to that in a second
when it comes to like poverty and mental
health these are more like
aspects where we say if poverty affects
people's decision-making and causes
behavioral biases or low productivity
and so on then things like hash
transfers and the why
uh might help that's necessarily not
sure that
counts as like paternalism that's more
like sort of support programs
and then i think like happiness and
mental health here you could think about
um if you think people are misoptimizing
in certain ways if they sort of under
use um uh psychological services or if
they sort of misoptimize in various ways
we think you know they could be
experimenting more they could be doing
more things to
improve their own happiness perhaps
there's some ways in which you could
push people to
to experiment more and try to figure
that out notice that i'm sort of
careful here in my wording i'm saying
pushing people to experiment and trying
things out
as opposed to like pushing people to do
certain things for example
if you say people should be working more
um and their work should be
working last and wow it's very hard for
the government to actually understand
what's good and bad
um but it could be like people are maybe
working too much and we could sort of
push them towards trying to think about
it and then see that what do they want
to experiment and sort of learn more
could they perhaps be happier by doing
so
any questions on this
so then um there's different forms of
paternalisms
that you can think about just hard
paternalism and there's soft paternalism
now what's hard journalism essentially
forcing choices on people
changing prices significantly mandate
choices or procedures
outlaw products or including um taxes so
you think of taxes sort of changing
prices
uh you can make things cheaper you can
make things more expensive to people
for people you can subsidize things you
can outlaw a prop
like up paternal agreement really
significantly changing people's
uh optimization problem uh in pretty
harsh ways
by essentially changing prices
potentially
um making some options infinitely
expensive right it's just to say look
i'm i'm just not allowing you to buy
certain goods
you can think of the price as just being
infinitely expensive for those goods so
that's hard for journalism
now in contrast there's other forms of
soft paternalism
there's two versions of that there's
what's called libertarian paternalism
which is what
sailor and sunstein are are known for
which are essentially policies that
constructively influence behavior while
preserving or nearly preserving freedom
of choice but that's essentially
not just that we talked about previously
that's essentially just saying like
you can choose whatever you want but i'm
trying to influence your behavior in
certain ways
that push you towards some options or
some outcomes that we think are
better than others right notice that the
government or the policy maker needs to
be very clear on what's good and what's
bad and then sort of try to understand
okay do you think here's some good
behavior that we have identified
let's now try to push you towards that
direction
but since we're kind of unsure what
what people want um we're not sort of
trying to exclude some option for some
people because we might
make things to worse for some people but
instead just try to push you towards
that
um very much related to that is what's
called a symmetric paternalism this is
um
the term from camera at all which are
policies that help people who make
mistakes while interfering minimally
with people who um behave optimally that
is to say
you want to be careful um if you see
people start
doing certain things you want to be
careful not to make things
worse for some people suppose some
people
for a share of the people like half of
the population is to the behavioral
agents they make a bunch of mistakes
and half of the population doesn't make
mistakes at all
now you could say and some people are
smoking and some people are not smoking
each of these
you might sort of say well the smokers
are making mistakes the behavioral
smokers are making mistakes so let's
help them
so they can attack smoking right now
what's going to happen is well you might
sort of improve some outcomes for those
people
and that might be good but there will be
other people who just like smoking and
they're just happy they're very happy to
smoke and they know that they're health
risks but they decide to smoke anyway
if you now start attack smoking you're
going to distort their choices and make
things worse off
for them so uh in particular
isometric paternalism is trying to avoid
that
by essentially saying like look we will
try to
come up with some some policies to make
things better for some people
but we want to be very careful not to
make things worse um for others in
particular people who are already
optimizing
anyway okay and so libertarian
paternalism is a version of that or it's
just very closely related with
essentially to say
if you preserve or nearly preserve
freedom of choice
then it often follows that you're not
going to make things
um worse for people optimizing anyway
right because if somebody's optimizing
anyway and i'm just essentially sort of
just providing small nudges one way or
the other
then often i'm not going to make things
worse for people optimizing anyway
that's not necessarily always the case
but it's pretty much
closely related i'm saying there could
be some people who just smoke they have
like five cigarettes a day and one
cigarette a day and there could be
there could be suppose there's two types
of people there's one type of people who
are essentially
making mistakes uh there have
internalities in the sense that
misunderstand the consequences of
smoking for their future self
these are people who make mistakes now
those people we might want to help
by increasing the price of smoking by
taxing it or in other ways
okay but there could be other people who
essentially are fully aware of the
consequences of smoking for the future
health
and those are optimizing and they're
essentially in the optimization
to decide that smoking is optimal for
them
those people might be made worse off by
cigarette taxes because essentially
what would you do with those taxes or
any other taxes you distort people's
behaviors
and um you know then we have a situation
where
we have potentially made some people
better off but also other people worse
off
and a lot of people would then be upset
or like unhappy about this because you
know
we say like look there's people who
screw up their choices or they don't
know what they're doing
uh they're trying to help them but now
that comes at the cost of others who are
actually perfectly optimizing and in
some sense that gets you in trouble
because you know they will be unhappy
people on the other
side of it potentially quite a few of
them all right
so what are not arguments against
paternalism or
you know why is paternalism bad you
might sort of say um
that sounds all pretty good but like now
you try to actually implement this
uh what's bad about it
so one typical argument is to say well
people make mistakes
well the government is made out of
people and so
uh how do we know that the people who
are in the government actually know
better
than people uh uh choose for themselves
and so if then the government
uh is is also making mistakes then
essentially choosing for others
it's not clear that it makes things
better or it could make things
worse in particular if you think that
the government
doesn't have enough information so i
know what's best for me
and so therefore um i'm best equipped to
make decisions for myself because you
might potentially
in particular if there's hydrogenated
you might make people some people better
off but that might come at the cost of
some others
and then it's not clear that on average
your overall be making things better
and that's a very important in
particular
um that comes up a lot in if you think
1475 for example which is political
economy
that would come up because you know
while we might want to help people we're
going to give people money but then the
government gets essentially a
village government or whatever gets like
captured by elites
to keep the money for themselves and so
the more
um they give the more opportunity they
give for that box with different
government resources and power
the more opportunities to uh for misuse
and corruption and so on and so forth
right so that's essentially saying that
so there's one class of argument is to
say well even if the government wanted
to
do the very best for people if the
government wanted eyes for
for for for its citizens that would be
hard to do because it doesn't know how
to do that it has inherent problems with
that
because of uh heterogeneity knowledge
issues and so on and so forth
um and then there's a second second type
of argument which um
um uh chad just mentioned which is
well who's there to say that the
government is actually
benevolent and actually wants people to
be better off maybe that just
want to get rich and so on and so forth
and so now if we let them make choices
then that opens the door for corruption
misuse of money and so on and so forth
so there's sort of a slippery slope
argument to say well there's some things
which i'm going to argue for some things
it's pretty clear that
we can make big things better or make
people some people at least better off
without hurting others and there's so
some cases where you say let's
have the government do that or whatever
the set policies that help people
by the way it doesn't have to be
necessarily the government but
also be like company
um but then you know i said well once we
start with like some things and they're
gonna do more things and at some point
they reach points for like the
government actually doesn't know what
they're doing and then they make things
um worse off so i have a bunch of
different
um arguments here i think you mentioned
quite a few of them
uh there's informational issues sort of
not understanding preferences people are
optimizing anyway
there's this is what carmen said you
know or we discussed previously that
people
some people's choices might be distorted
so these are issues of heterogeneity
often
uh then the sort of the government is
terrible and wastes money anyway
um the government doesn't have like
people's best
interests and minds just regulatory
capture i think
this is also what um uh chad mentioned
uh freedom of choice then there's some
other arguments which is freedom of
choice matters per se that's a little
trickier to address but just here look
that's just
i want to choose for myself and i don't
want the government to tell me anything
and that's important by itself this is
not about the outcome this is about the
freedom of choice mattering itself
um then there's a similarly there's
arguments about the good people just
don't like hard paternalism they just
don't like to be told or like
certain options uh to be
excluded for those reasons perhaps
partially because they don't want the
government to be
powerful and then there's finally
there's some sort of practical problems
which is
you know once we agree that we want sort
of some paternalistic policies
which policy should we choose and how do
we know what it would which is better
than another i'm going to get back to
that in a bit as well
there's also practical implementation
problems just to say the government even
if the government wanted to do the right
things
the government is often like inefficient
and so on and so forth and so it's
just costly to do and practically it's
just hard to do certain things
now what are arguments in favor i'm
going to just
speed things up a bit so the arguments
in paper are often like very simple
which is that people make mistakes
people screw up and they can help them
potentially screw up less
um people often also don't like to
necessarily make choose choices for
themselves that could be just because
they don't
like doing it it could also be just it's
costly to do that and that's just
there's some activities that are just
hard to do
and i'd rather have somebody regulate
this for me as opposed to like
me having to choose or make these
choices all for myself
an example would be suppose you know
there's like insurance plans or some
form of like retirement plans and so on
if there's some options that are just
terrible and they just would be
exploiting me and making me worse off
i could probably figure it out if you
gave me these plans and like i spent
like a day
um studying them but you know i have
like better stuff to do and i'd rather
have somebody else screen out sort of
the bad plans
and sort of then offer me sort of the
the choices that
try to not exploit me and then make
maybe
some choices from a limited set that's
not to say i couldn't do it but it's
just sort of saying it's inefficient for
me to
to deal with these things um on my own
now and then finally and this is i think
one of the most important arguments is
that
there are a lot of soft paternalism
regimes where people can opt out
and are unaffected potentially so when
you go back to like the previous
concerns
um that people might have these are
often arguments against hard
journalism these are often things about
like government wasting money and so on
and so forth
if this is about like sending reminders
or like
phrasing letters in one way versus
another in some simple ways
or putting food or putting apples next
to like the counter versus like candy
bars
this is not about the government taking
over or like restricting people's free
choice
it's rather to say which trying to make
people better off in some simple ways
you need to do and um
and so a lot of these uh criticism or
arguments go away once you go into like
soft paternalism um
territory and so then um
at the end of the day i think it's hard
to make arguments often for
journalism because you need to be very
confident things right
it's much easier to argue for
self-paternalism
simple policies that are not expensive
that arguably are not
hurting a lot of people but make at
least some people um better off
um now i think uh so it's a little hard
to see maybe um but
sometimes it's actually quite hard to
figure out whether people are making
mistakes
this is for example here um uh um
a survey from gallup that looks at
americans and looks at like
um people uh who call themselves very or
somewhat overweight versus
the percentage who are overweight and
obese by some standards by the cdc and
so on
and so here you see essentially that
people tend to
uh the fraction war of these
tends to be quite high intensity
increasing by people's perception of
that might be
not necessarily the case now in some
ways like who are we to sort of say that
people should change their behaviors or
that they're making mistakes so in some
situations at least it's quite tricky to
figure out
what's a mistake and what's not and what
to be do or not
and again you get into tricky issues um
when it comes to particular for
different selves and self-control where
again who are we just saying that uh
somebody should lose weight or change
their behavior in certain ways
um when perhaps um that's not in their
best interest or that's not what they're
doing maybe they're fully optimizing
and how how would we even know that
that's not the case
now what are some forms of paternalisms
that are quite
um popular there's lots of examples of
in fact quite popular
paternalism there's social security
there's healthcare program for retirees
including medicare which tends to be
quite popular
uh there's often restrictions of um
investment menus and 401k savings plans
where essentially that's precisely what
i was just saying is where
um essentially just bad plans so
dominated plants are often just excluded
um there's often consumer safety
regulations that the fda
essentially certain drugs cannot be
offered like you cannot take certain
drugs
the government essentially just sort of
if they're not being safe
um there's mandatory education and many
places you have to go to school you
can't just sort of say i'm just
sort of uh um i'm
my kid is sort of learning at the forest
that's sort of not an option
um often that's to do with also like
protection of miners in some ways
um then there's cigarette taxes or sin
taxes that's
often called that's also hard
paternalism notice that here you're
changing people's prices
uh in many places uh prostitution
polygamy
are are banned these are like hard bands
so you can just you're just not allowed
to like um
marry three spouses um uh
mandating face mask interestingly it
seems to me that that's hard paternalism
as you have for example in uh
in cambridge i think that the punishment
is currently 300 if you go outside and
don't wear a face mask
i'm pretty sure in cambridge that's
quite popular notice of course that's
not true in all states
and so on so there might be some
policies that are very much popular
in some places but not at all in others
there's also some um soft paternalism
that tends to be quite
um popular um there's some places where
like it's not clear whether it's like
hard versus soft paternalism what
exactly the definition is
things like banning junk food and school
vending machines you can call that sort
of heart paternalism because you take
away
options but of course it doesn't really
uh prevent you from bringing in candy to
school anyway so like call that hardest
off patrols and um i don't really care
about that tends to be quite
a popular policy uh calorie disclosure
laws which essentially just
saying like you have to put in some
information for our customers
which could be easily available you can
just look it up online or the like
and things like default enrollment in
401ks dating span all tend to be quite
popular now and for some
goods you know there's like huge um um
uh taxes for example cigarette taxes
tend to be extremely high
this is from 2019 um notice that there's
huge variation across
um places if you look at like you know
some places here these are like some of
the highest
um uh uh such as um connecticut's uh
including massachusetts it's three four
um dollars per pack of cigarettes
in addition there's also like a dollar
from the federal government
then there's some other places including
um uh
you know uh uh north dakota or like
um north carolina and so on where
cigarette taxes are extremely
low so that's kind of quite interesting
because it sort of
it says you know here's a policy that
depending on your view
of how people make choices governments
make very different decisions
and presumably that has to do with like
freedom of choice
or uh the popularity of that choice
itself
in the specific state of course it also
has to do with potentially
um the party and so on uh similarly
there's also an aspiration in
state alcohol taxes um they're in fact
um they're very like hugely uh
particular sort of
you find some states where like the um
the
taxes per per gallon or like you know
twenty thirty dollars and some other
states where it's like essentially close
to zero
um notice that there's also a bunch of
other um
blue laws as they're referred to which
is things like on certain days you're
not allowed to sell alcohol
uh and so on now that's kind of
interesting because that sort of
additional restrictions
um uh which would tend to be quite
um inefficient in various ways that is
to say
so economists would tend to think that
like if there's certain behavior that
you don't want people to engage in
we should tax it um instead um you could
essentially sort of outlaw it in certain
ways that tends to be quite inefficient
because often people find ways to get
any way plus the government does not get
any taxes or revenue
um from that now
what are some unpopular um paternalism
or things that people don't like
quickly i think that's exactly right so
one of them is helmets and
seat belts so there often
it's there's no externality here this is
essentially just like something to
protect yourself
now they tend to be quite unpopular in
many places
um it's not quite clear why that is
so often it's sort of a thing that's not
cool or like a sort of some social norms
or in some ways where people sort of
think
it's like another thing they want to do
it's like uh sort of explaining to my
14 year or 15 year old niece to wear
like a helmet is sort of very hard
and then she would say yes yes but then
like drive around like ride her bike
around the corner and then take it off
and sort of you know and so on
so that seems to be about sort of
something about
personal trade-offs between risk and
rewards in some ways where
uh you know the government of some
people um might just
not value the benefits of
looking cool or whatever sufficiently or
as much as the individual itself and
then they tend to be sort of um
uh unhappy about it of course the
alternative way of putting this is that
the individual itself
is underestimating the risk potentially
of doesn't take into account how bad it
would be to actually have a bicycle
accident
right but that's essentially something
about people
disagreeing with the government with
their parents or the like about
the risk versus reward or cost benefits
of certain actions
and there seems to be disagreement and
then you could sort of mandate that but
that
leads to unhappiness because they're
precisely that disagreement
now the wearing mask is in some
sense quite similar there it's quite
different and what's different here is
that there's externalities right so
their externalities here are
that certain people benefit a lot from
having their shops open
or like being able to sell things
and others are affected a lot so in
particular the elderly
might might be disproportionately
affected and sort of might essentially
uh the number of people who will die
will clearly if people are not wearing
masks or if shops are not a few people
are
running out of outside or meeting and so
on and so forth
um but there's others who are really um
for whom that's really costly because
their businesses are not open
and they like now that could be there
could be
entirely rational um issues
um where you might say well um uh people
just don't care about certain uh
other groups of the society and
therefore you want to have your shop
open and you
don't want to be told um that what that
you should be doing that
there could be also mistakes in the
sense that people just don't understand
necessarily these externalities they
might sort of say well
um i'm not effective and i'll be just
fine that might be actually
the risk for themselves is not that high
but of course there's
um large externalities and others that
they might sort of not appreciate or not
take into account
uh exactly so so chad carmen is saying
speed limits uh similarly are similar to
that
because they're sort of like i'm driving
but there's affect yourself but also
um in certain accidents
and so um why is that or what
so how do we think about
[Music]
to say so i mentioned here
and this is an example so here we have
um we think sort of sicknesses
are quite um popular and why is that
popular and why is the
uh making certain drugs illegal
why is that unpopular what's the problem
here
so i think there's when you think about
when you do like economic
analysis of that there's essential you
can think of this
might be externality values might
actually much lower than for
smoking or drinking because uh drunk
driving and so on is very
lethal there might be also some
expertise from
smoking weed um but um uh the
externalities are surely looking for
preferred drinking now then there could
be melodies but again for internalities
usually the solution would be just the
typical sin taxes and so on you would
say well you want to tax it
sure but then you at least would get
some revenue you would increase the
price you would get some revenue for the
government
um plus you would lower people's
consumption um
in addition there's all this stuff about
like um
locking people up unnecessarily by
making it illegal essentially you create
like a large prisoner
population and so on which surely is for
society so once you sort of have like
these
policies there's actually not a lot of
reasons for
uh for outlawing these are sort of tend
to be
um sort of gut reactions or some sort of
judgments that were made at some point
there's some lobby arguing in favor of
alcohol and maybe less of a lobby
arguing for other drugs
um but as you say you know the sentiment
has very much changed and it seems to be
like sooner or later
pretty much all states are moving uh
towards
south asia and that leads to essentially
potential government
uh uh revenues um
as well so i think one argument perhaps
that one could make is sort of these
gateway direct
arguments which you know i don't think
there's actually that much
evidence for that but you say well
actually sort of um
uh mariana might not be so bad by itself
but perhaps it leads to like other words
it's not obvious at all that
legalization um of that
so hey it's not obvious that that's
necessarily true but b it's all obvious
that making it legal
versus illegal changes that rationale
because
when it's illegal lots of people are
using drugs anyway and maybe it makes it
even more
and maybe sort of more dangerous um
potentially
but i think it's important to sort of
realize that some of these policies are
very much like sort of
in some ways arbitrary um based on some
legacy or some lobbies and so on and so
forth
and what's important here is that the
the popularity itself then also will
affect policies in some ways
like you know as you say you know the
public sentiment has shifted in various
in some ways stuff will become legal uh
as a result of that and once you do it
in some states and things seem fine and
the states make a bunch of money from it
a lot of other states eventually will
follow um
in part because it's also you know much
harder to
enforce laws if you have a bunch of
surrounding states where you can
um buy stuff legally and that makes it
of course trickier than to sort of
enforce the law um
anyway um i have some other unpopular
uh uh examples of popular paternalism
um junk food bans um
junk food taxes and some of these things
again are changing over time so
like you know um uh i might well be that
um things are
are different in 10 20 years from now uh
gambling laws pornography laws
uh other kinds of syntaxes um
mandating face masks again and some
states are just really really popular
and people on the streets
um protesting against it which is quite
um quite interesting john cena
might be but often it is the case that
there are
some forms of there is real economic
interests
um behind that often and perhaps um
again that could be very much fully
rational uh it could also be that people
might misunderstand the externalities
that are
at play um there's some other sort of
kinds of heart paternalism that's also
kind of unpopular and also not a
particular efficient thing to do
which is things like the ban on 16-ounce
sodas
which is kind of like a weird thing to
do if you think about it because you can
just buy smaller
smaller bottles of the leg and it tends
to be quite inefficient
um um overall uh here's a
signs for for for seat belts
um now okay so here's the
legalization which also does massive um
variation of prostates
now there's some um nudges and some
policies have
massive impacts and we studied at least
some of this for example this was
automatic enrollment there there's
essentially
a huge swing towards that essentially
lots of
companies and so on they're now using
that and
the fraction of people who are uh uh
participating in retirement plans is way
higher than the fraction
of people when there's voluntary there's
other policies which are quite simple
policies
um uh which are things um
uh trying to get people to appear in
court
there essentially lots of
lots of um uh
people who have to appear in court um
for like initial court hearings
tend to not show up in those meetings
and as you can imagine that's not a
great idea because you know that that
essentially leads to like
uh potentially really bad consequences
now what you can essentially just do is
try to
do very simple policies and there's a
very nice paper by obelious and others
who looks at this
you can sort of change the forms you can
phrase things differently
that essentially tries to nudge people
in the right direction
um you can also do things like text
message reminders and the text messages
window just says your court date
is on may 22 at 9am
please show up and you remind people to
do that
and what you get essentially is that you
get large
decreases in timely court appearances or
non-appearances where the fraction won't
show up in court to their own court
hearing
decreases a lot by using very very
simple
policies once you do those kinds of
policies presumably
much to say against this policy in the
sense that
uh you might say well so hey you're not
restricting anybody's choices
you're also not really making anybody
worse off by sending some text message
reminders there might be some small
inconveniences of receiving these text
messages which are kind of
annoying in spam for some people but
overall like nobody is really made off
by
by this it's a very cheap thing to do so
there's not a lot of
arguments against such policies where
you say look here's a policy that's
extremely cheap to do some people are
benefiting presumably showing up in
court is a good thing
for your court hearing and it's cheap
things to do
um and the benefits are potentially
large because you'll now be prevent some
people for
from uh essentially ending up in jail
for uh uh
too long or for unnecessary time because
they failed to appear to their hearings
okay but to them i think it's also
important so there's some examples that
essentially show large effects including
automatic enrollment
including things like text messages or
some uh
interventions to induce court
appearances
um but it's important to understand that
not everything always works
what you sort of see often or what i've
shown you
are examples of successful examples of
stuff that works
but there's some examples just don't
work at all so here's an example of a
clinical trial which is called the heart
strong randomized
clinical trial which gave people
essentially like a kitchen sink of
things that we think are all good things
to do
this is stuff like reminders financial
incentives social support
and so on and so forth for people
essentially who had heart attacks
by giving them like wireless models
lottery based incentives
uh and again social support by sort of
having um
friends and family to to help them and
essentially that did exactly
nothing for people and sort of had no
effect whatsoever
so it's not to say that like we think
like everything works always and like we
should just always nudge people and
provide incentives and so on and so
forth
it's something that like might work but
in fact there's no reason to think that
it might always work
in some situations this might be helpful
and others um
not more concerningly there's also
recently and there's a very recent paper
from stefano lavina that just came out
like a week ago that looks at um
academic studies and nudged units
that's to say what they're trying to do
is look at treatment effects in academic
studies that are published in papers
which are papers like yeah uh the the
stuff that we saw on default effects and
so on which is carol at all is one of
the following key savings one
there's here's the um the study on fafsa
enrollment that i showed you
there's some changing order of
menu orders in buffet line for healthier
food consumption so there's a bunch of
sort of papers that usually you would
teach in like a typical class
and what you see here is on the x-axis
or so on the y-axis you see treatment
effects and percentage points
on the x-axis you see the control group
take up which is to say
if you don't do anything what does the
control group do
and what you see is pretty large effect
in many of these studies that are
published there's some questions on this
is like u-shaped or inverse you whatever
let's ignore that for a second but
overall what you see is pretty large
treatment effects in
situations when you then look at
and this is like 20 cl6 trials and set
71 different
nudges here when you instead look at
uh nudge units so what are nudge units
these are essentially
for example the uk government has the
uh what's called the bit the behavioral
insights team
which essentially is a team inside the
uk government
that tries to support or like nudge
people to make better choices that's
very much sort of like
coming from the nudge movement from
failure and so on that sort of like
advise the uk government to set this up
and they're now nudging away because the
government is really happy about cheap
stuff that doesn't cost
very much but potentially has like large
benefits
now what then um
what they then also do often is they
evaluate their
interventions in part because they try
to figure out what works best
now when you look at these interventions
you see essentially that the
treatment effects in those kinds of
interventions tend to be much larger
than on the left if you look at the
right there's a bunch of stuff on just
massive bunch of points that are pretty
high above 10 20
when you look to the right essentially
you see almost everything is between
zero and ten percent
uh a lot of it seems to be not
statistically significantly differently
from
uh different from zero so that should
give us some pause
uh in the sense of like we should be
careful and and sort of necessarily
recommending a bunch of stuff to
governments and saying like we should
always nudge and so on and so forth
um what's going on here well some of
this could be about
uh publication bias like essentially
there's a bunch of studies that are
being run and what's being published is
essentially stuff that's highly
significant and flashy and important
there could be also issues with
implementation that maybe what's done
with researchers
is sort of implemented better
potentially
and maybe what's done at scale it's just
harder to do a nudge units and harder to
carefully and then the effects might be
lower not to say that governments
shouldn't nudge in the sense that like
if they would if there are effects of
the order of magnitude of something like
5
and that's really percentage points and
that's really cheap to do you should
probably do it anyway
um but it's just the same not just are
not the magic bullet that sort of
changed everything that the government
should always engage on them
and it's quite important in fact for the
government or governments or any sort of
these
policy units and firms by the way the
exact same thing
to try and figure out what works and
what doesn't and not just rely on the
academic evidence that
uh might sort of be more proof of
concept rather than sort of something
that
evaluates cost effectiveness any
questions on this
now another question this is a little
blurry um another question you might ask
um and you might have seen these kinds
of letters before
whether everybody wants to be notched
and so what um there's a very
famous study by alcott and others that
look at
energy comparisons that's a study done
with o power of the company
um that essentially tries to reduce
energy usage
and the way this works is what you do is
um you send people
these kinds of letters and i'm getting
these letters um too that sort of says
here's your
um here's your energy consumption in the
last
month the month last year here is
um all of your neighbors so it's a
comparison you see
this the blue bars like how much did you
use and the
the gray bars like how much did all of
your neighbors use
and then there's the green bar that sort
of says how much do efficient neighbors
use
and then there's like smileys where you
have like uh two smileys if you're doing
great one smiley if you're doing good
like this
fellow here and then there's no smiley i
guess if you're
if you're not doing well sometimes
there's also like a sad smiley if you're
using lots of energy and so on
and so then there's some essentially
what this is trying to do is trying to
provide some social comparison here
it's a very cheap policy to do in
particular um
when you're sending sort of energy bills
anyway it's very cheap to sort of add
this at the top
where essentially you're sending people
energy bills anyway and now you're sort
of adding the social comparison to try
to nudge people to use less energy
um there's a question of why the company
might do that but that's sort of like a
separate
issue and what you see here is when you
look at
people when you look at treatment
effects there tends to be
clear treatment effects at least some
treatment effects of
providing this kind of information
reduces
overall energy
consumption of rcts that people have
now one question you might ask is well
shouldn't we
then always do this so what's the reason
not to do that and it turns out
not everybody um wants to be notched so
here's an intervention where
now again alcott and co-author have now
in fact asked people about would you
like to receive these letters
and what they ask is would you like to
receive these kinds of social
comparisons
and what they ask is um uh what's your
positive willingness to pay for it
so would you like to have a dollar
versus these reports
boy so a dollar no no reports versus um
just receiving the reports
what is people's willingness to pay but
they also ask their willingness to pay
not to receive these reports that is to
say i could either tell you
i i would ask you like you receive a
dollar um
at no reports or um uh or sorry
you receive zero dollars and no reports
or received a dollar and the reports and
some people sort of turned that down
which essentially implies that they'd
rather have one
or less and no reports they are willing
to pay not to receive these reports
and this is what you see here on the
left is essentially people's willingness
to pay for home reports
so there are quite a few people here on
the right who have positive willingness
to pay they think it's kind of useful
it's kind of interesting maybe it helps
them reduce their energy consumption
maybe that motivates them in certain
ways
but some people are just like saying
essentially i do not want these reports
the reason being that essentially it's
kind of just annoying to like
get nag all the time if you want to sort
of maybe in some cases you just don't
have a lot of choice
in some cases maybe you just like to use
lots of energy for whatever reason
and it's really annoying to be told all
the time that you're like neighbor is
really better than you are
uh makes people look just uncomfortable
and makes them unhappy and so on and so
forth
uh maybe it makes them feel guilty who
knows um
maybe just don't want to think about it
but importantly
there are some people who just do not
want to be nudged
and i think that's important um because
you know when you think back about the
libertarian paternalism or the
soft paternalism criteria asymmetric
paternalism that we
talked about well what the asymmetric
paternalism would say is we should not
make anybody
um worse off so now if you send all
these letters and make actually people
feel people
uncomfortable then in fact we are
potentially making people
um worse up and you can think about some
other types of
uh intervention if you think about if
you got like letters from my tells you
all the time how are you doing compared
to
um classmates of
um uh uh study efforts in terms of like
problem sets and changes and so on
um potentially you know that would
likely
increase study efforts in some ways and
we would perhaps increase learning in
some ways
but it's not clear at all that we would
increase welfare because maybe everybody
would be even more stressed and
everybody would sort of
be less happy and so on and so forth at
least
in some cases um
yeah so um actually so jenna is asking a
question about like who's unhappy about
this
um i think
what's so inside so the isometric
paternalism is just to say
suppose there are some people who are
just very happy with that choice about
using logi
and they just don't want to be nudged
they don't want to they're fully
rationally choosing this
maybe they know sort of deep down in
their heart and it's bad to like uh ruin
the
the planets and climate and so on and so
forth but they really made a choice that
they want
lots of energy those people are not the
people who want to receive any letters
so things geometric patronalism would
say
we should just leave them alone they
should just be doing whatever they want
to do
and us sending them letters to make them
feel bad if they don't even change their
behavior anyway
or even if they would change their
behavior that's not for us to say and we
should just leave them alone because you
make them worse off by receiving these
letters
by the revealed preference to say
they're willing to pay not to receive
these letters
now there could be some situations where
people who have potentially large
treatment effects these are people who
use lots of
energy and they just don't know about it
and those we want to sort of
send them letters and push them but i
think the whole point of the paternalism
is metropolitan
is to say we shouldn't make anybody
worse off so if somebody
reveals to us by their preference which
is what these fellows are doing here
that they really don't want to receive
these letters we should um
uh respect that and so the one then one
potential solution here is then to say
well why don't we just let people opt
out but you just say okay
you send people these letters and then
you have to click on something or like
you have to sort of opt in or opt out
and then maybe people who really don't
want to receive these letters
we can essentially just um let them be
that there's no judgment here in terms
of like is that socially
uh like what do we want to do when is
this a good or bad thing
this is just to say we should respect
people's um uh preferences in certain
ways
does that make sense
um now the next question you might ask
is well
what form should paternalism take and
that's the thing sometimes
it's important because you know you
could uh take 401k savings policies
you can come up with a lot of different
options in which you could design your
um um your 401k savings policies
you could say you could have like active
decisions you could have defaults for
participation
you have like defaults for less
information
you have like a personal financial
planner um sitting down with you
you might have like a minimum amount of
this is like as hard paternal as minimum
amount of non-zero for one key savings
trade merchants just force people to
save
and it's important to say it's it's not
just about paternalism versus
non-paternalism once you get into the
paternalism realm it's actually very
hard to figure out
what you do because there's so many
different options and it's hard to
tell which one is better than the other
more generally even it's actually quite
hard to come up with any like
non-paternalism option that is to say
you can think of like all the options
that are there in some sense once you
think that defaults affect people's
decisions
the no um savings default is also a form
of paternalism in some sense you say you
choose something for people
and that's going to push them to not
safe or you choose to hide
like there's nothing special about the
zero
we also have a ten percent savings
default and so it's almost like regard
is
it's important to understand that
regardless what choice you choose you're
going to affect
people's choices and their behaviors in
certain ways and so
that sort of means essentially that um
you have to take a stance
in which you sort of change affect
people's behavior
in a way just saying like we're just
choosing a zero
savings defaults and something's just a
cop-out
because even the zero savings default is
affecting people's behavior um
quite a bit so in a way the discussion
should rather be about like
what is the optimal way of the optimal
paternalism
soft paternalism i would argue rather
than sort of saying paternalism versus
not because regardless of what option
you choose you're going to affect
behaviors in certain ways
because precisely the way you provide
information to people on the default
frames etc
affect people's choices does that make
sense
okay so here's a very quick example of
like a very
useful and and hopefully example of
libertarian
paternalism that has been quite
successful
the theology bernardi uh uh were
asked to design a forward key savings
for a company
that wanted to increase its employees
savings
so the companies hired a financial
advisor the employers could sit down
with the advisor to violate the
financial situation
plan so for those who agreed to talk to
the advisor the reviser
he i guess in this case recommended a
savings rate some agreed to implement
this and then bernardi and taylor got
the leftovers so that's
arguably that's um sort of negatively
selected
uh towards um saving um a lot
now what's the then the smart the save
more tomorrow plan
uh employees were then approached about
increasing their contribution rate um
uh uh one typical time before the next
scheduled pay rates so that's to say
before the next scheduled periods they
were essentially asked about
whether they would like to join
voluntarily and if they wanted to do
um they their contribution to the plan
was going to be increased beginning with
the first paycheck after the race
so that's to say if i told you like in
december you're going to get a pay raise
would you like to increase your
contribution
then once you receive that pay raise and
so then
um you could choose like a or there's a
preset maximum
and then what would happen is the
contribution rate would automatically
increase
over time with each pay raise that you
would receive like suppose your pay
raise is like say five percent or three
percent
what you would get then is like um uh
suppose it's three percent you
have like only like a two percent
increase in your pay rate pay
and one percent or one percentage point
if you pay would then go towards the
retirement contribution
importantly the employee can opt out of
the plan at any point in time by
essentially just
making a phone call or um the like
now why is this plan um a
libertarian paternalism well because of
aspects two and four
right it's voluntary so you can do
whatever you want you you can you don't
have to choose
this at all you can essentially decline
it you can also opt out at any point in
time so it's
arguably nobody is worse made worse off
because you essentially what we're doing
here is
um increasing people's options but say
here's an option for you to like
increase to saving automatically over
time
um and you can leave it out you can
leave it whenever you would like um to
do so arguably nobody should be worse
off
on uh by this and potentially some
people are made
better off um quite a bit and that's
exactly what you see here
essentially um when you look at the
people who joined the smart plan
um notice that this is not random here
so there's some you know
concerns about identification but
setting that aside
um if you look at the people who again
like arguably are negatively selected
these are people
who declined um
the financial consult and they
essentially increased their savings
dramatically
uh as a consequence of this smart plan
and now the smart plan has been
introduced or implemented in quite a few
um
places but anyway that's not the point
here i wanted to say
um what's good about the plan is well
it's a smart plan uh
not just because of the acronym but also
because it's using um
behavioral principles or stuff that we
learned in class um
uh quite a bit and carefully so what are
these principles so why is this a useful
plan
um to use and i'm gonna sort of show you
again what the plan is
what's clever about this plan what is it
using carefully
by the way i don't know if you can hear
this background noise this is my
neighbor has engaged in various
uh home uh home uh improvement project
projects
since the quarantine um uh um
i've so far um refrain from
uh complaining about it because i don't
know what's going on in their lives
otherwise and um
maybe that's sort of a way of uh dealing
with stress
and so on you can hear this the default
once you
opt in the default is for your uh pay
writing
the the contribution rate to increase so
the default is essentially working
towards
increasing people's savings okay so
there's two things going on here one is
prison buys when you say well yeah in
the future i want to save more
so precisely that's kind of great
because you know now like the future
itself will be virtuous and so on so
people are present bias that will help
and then um there's also just the the
part that's about
uh uh paycheck increases remember people
tend to be philosophers
so um what this plan is also
accomplishing is like so if i'm asking
you right now today would you like to
increase your savings rate
well not only are you press buyers but
also you're gonna have like a cut in
your paycheck and people hate cuts in
their paychecks
so instead it's saying like well in the
future your rates will be lower
and people are less averse to reducing
those
um increases um compared to
experiencing pay cuts so that's i think
what we have here so this is essentially
prison bias is helping
then there's reference dependence and
then there's defaults that help
people switching out or some form of
present bias but people precisely as we
said previously people are not switching
out of those kinds of plans
so if you think that's a good thing to
increase people's savings here that's
something
because people might actually
procrastinate switching out of it once
they're in in the first place
so that seems to be like a a great
example because not only is it
preserving libertarian uh or is it is it
preserving people's free choice and not
people
making people um uh worse off but also
it's using in a smart way
um behavioral um principles okay
let me briefly talk about the market and
we talked about this a little bit
already previously but i want to sort of
make this um
explicit so one um argument that often
comes
in particular out of other um is well
um if people have self-control problems
or other issues well will not the market
come up with some goods or some
solutions that will help people right
after all there's like money to be made
um in improving people's choices
so if really self-control problems so
the like are really important
why is not having anybody coming up with
a market solution and sort of a great
product that helps people and then
they're going to make a lot of money
um from doing so and so in particular if
consumers are feeling
sophisticated then they demand uh ways
to change the consumption
and then there will be somebody who's
providing that good
and you know if the welfare effects of
those kinds of
uh uh self-control or other distortions
are large well then you can make a lot
of money from helping people
improve their behavior so what's what's
problematic with this
um uh line of argument well the market
is precisely part of the problem well so
on the one hand you sort of say if you
try to
so this is google and this is quite a
while ago but you know uh
right now it's in some sense more
sophisticated ways and there's lots of
targeting going on
but if you google impulsive credit card
spending what you're going to get is a
bunch of advice to help you with that
but at the same time you also get a
bunch of credit card offers that are
like you're going to get targeted
eventually by
companies that might essentially
precisely exploit you
so on the one hand you there will be a
side of the market you will potentially
help you
but there's another side of the market
will you want to to exploit you
and uh importantly what the market will
do is firms will try to target naive
people and you might remember this from
lectures
five and six where essentially firms
precisely try to find people um
um who are perhaps um left sophisticated
financially in other ways
so the firms are precisely trying to
target naive people because those are
the people you can exploit
moreover the naives are the ones who
will think
well i don't have any problems so i
don't actually need any goods or any
sort of products that might help you
so not only are they being targeted by
people who try to
decide to screw them over but also they
actually
are um reluctant to seek help because
precisely
um uh uh they think they're not even
they think it's not even necessary to
seek help
so even a firm who wants to help has
trouble making money with us because
people
if they're naive will not necessarily
understand that
um help is required and that's precisely
the tension that we see in many markets
where there's some firms who might want
to
help and support in this case
self-control that's also true for other
um issues but there's on the other side
funds that try to break down uh the
self-control from consumers precisely
because they can make much much a bunch
of money
um from that and so now um
uh the second part then severely limits
the market's ability to provide
self-control because it's essentially
too forced to start work
now the government of course can sort of
uh try to address this and this is what
behavioral io would be about behavioral
i o would be about saying
uh industrial organization which would
be well there's behavioral consumers
there's firms to try to
exploit consumers now the government is
trying to support
um or like by some form of regulation
trying to
help customers particular things like
the uh
consumer financial protection bureau and
so on trying to help
um consumers not to get exploited by
banning advertising by capping interest
rates and so on and so forth
also by for example um
mandating disclosure and so on and so
forth
um now um i'm going to say one final
thing about nudges um which is
on the one hand we talked about nudges
in the sense of saying
look there's some behavior that we're
trying to improve which would be like
you know suppose people keep forgetting
um certain things to take their
medication or to appear in court
let's send reminders to um
uh to to improve behaviors you can set
defaults in certain ways and so on and
so forth
which is policies to improve good
behaviors
assuming that the person who makes those
choices but has been
benevolent in certain ways now on the
other hand of course
firms can use the same techniques on the
same um
approaches to do the exact opposites and
just to harm people and this is what um
uh uh thalain sunstein calls sludges
which essentially is like using these
nudges and
and bad ways by um trying to push people
in wrong directions
so an example of that would be offering
rebates on a product
and then having people customers to
require to
to mail in forms of delight and you may
have encountered these and wondering
like why i have to
mail in this form and this is kind of
tedious and then you end up not doing it
you want to think oh i'm getting like
this great discount
and then actually never send it in
because then they don't have to actually
pay
they can sell you the good but then you
don't have to actually they don't have
to give you the discount at the end of
the day
so there's a bunch of types of uh cases
both from the private sector but also
from the public sector such as things
says voter registration
when you think about it why is voter
division hard in certain places
well the reason why it's hard is because
certain parties and groups do not want
certain types of groups of people to
vote
and those are essentially deliberate
ways of making it hard for people to to
make choices that are arguably good for
them or for society
and that's what they learned sunshine
would call sludges
and then here it's important to realize
that it's in fact
identifying and eliminating such sludges
which essentially are
certain ways that make it hard for
people to make good choices for
themselves or for society
can be equally important or perhaps as
important as sort of
implementing nudges to improve people's
behavior in certain ways so it's not
just about sort of taking behavior where
people on their own screw up in certain
ways and trying to improve them and
trying to help them
but rather helping people uh being
misdirected in certain ways
um to to be exploited
and in many cases in particular in
companies identifying those kinds of
sludges
and uh calling companies out gets it
pretty far
gets you pretty far in some sense on
social media but like
once called out companies often back
down and try to reduce them because they
did
they don't want to have bad reputations
of exploiting um
customers okay so let me sort of
summarize the lecture and then briefly
and two minutes the whole class
um so some forms of particular soft
paternalism can ambiguously improve
welfare and we should be quite excited
about them and they can help quite a bit
now on the other end not just can also
make things worse in particular if the
government doesn't know
what's good for people and we want to be
careful and nudging
there's some examples happen in class
but there's also some
examples of nudges actually backfiring
now in addition to that some people
dislike being mentioned
we should respect that and take that
into account we try to maximize
utility remember as opposed to like um
certain behaviors or take up of certain
outcomes and you want to be careful not
to make people worse off
in helping people opt out of certain
languages or certain
events should be quite helpful in
addition the market does not solve
everything
so we should not have faith in like the
market solving things in particular the
market might um uh make things worse
um finally uh reducing sludges can go a
long way in improving behavior um
overall now a big picture summary of
this class um
what is it in one slide that i want you
to take away and have
i've learned of course things are more
complicated but let me give you like a
very brief summary so one psychological
considerations are or can be quite
important in a lot of economic choices
and behaviors we should take them
very seriously for you personally i
think that means in some ways
understanding your own biases and
mistakes and issues better and try to
improve decision making
seems quite important that's true for
short run or simple sort of
considerations such as you know how to
deal with procrastination and exercising
and so on
it's also true for long run
considerations like which which jobs do
you want to have which friends do you
want to keep and so on and so forth
uh it could make you perfect you're
unhappy in the future
and you want to be quite mindful um
about that
small changes or like thinking about
things um for a while can make big
differences
so i think i very much encourage you to
introspect be more mindful and mindful
and your choices
um as i said last time experimenting
seeking advice
including psychological support and so
on seem to be quite helpful
at the same time you also shouldn't
stress too much and sort of just try to
be happy
and don't be too harsh on yourself uh
often people are doing quite well
already um overall
it's also worth understanding that
sometimes it's actually easier to help
your friends or others than yourself
it's often easier to see in others how
they're mis-optimizing
and how to improve their behaviors so in
some ways helping others
um might be in fact one of the things
you might have taken away
from this class um and then finally you
know you want to think about in
particular when you think about like
designs of teams working with others
incentives products and so on if you try
to design an app or any website or
thinking about psychological
considerations of designing things
is quite important that you should take
those things
into account um somebody was asking
about books to read so i just sort of
added them here
i was planning to say a little bit more
but i'm sort of out of time so i'm just
leaving this here i'll try to add like a
couple of sentences for each of
um there are some quite amazing books
that you can read
in particular for example chaldini's 93
influence books is amazing book to read
daeneryeli has really nice books
including predictably irrational
some of these are more basic um than
others
um if you're interested in poverty milan
athena and shafir's scarcity book is
really an amazing um
uh read and then danny kahneman's uh
thinking fast and slow
um it's also like um uh extremely
insightful and interesting
um of course there's other brooks for
example dick taylor talks about the
history of behavioral economics
uh lewis uh is the what's called the
undoing project which is about
uh conor mcgregor's friendship and how
they sort of essentially came to
uh in some really important ways uh
revolutionizing
uh some parts of economics so there's
lots of things to read
uh if you're interested in any of these
just let me know i'm very happy to
to to chat so that's that's pretty much
all i have to say i have lots of fun
uh teaching this class i know this
semester was was tricky and difficult
um for many of us i i uh every um time i
teach this class i'm surprised how much
i learned i hope you learned some useful
things too
um i guess uh this is from last time so
there's no course evaluations this this
year
we might do an informal or informal one
um to just want to try to think about uh
learn more about what you thought we did
already in informal
relationship but that was assuming that
there will be actual evaluations this
semester
unfortunately mit has sort of canceled
them this year uh i think to be mindful
for some people are particularly
affected by
um uh uh the quarantine and so on uh
come to my office hours you have
questions
um uh i have some europe opportunities
some of you have already applied to
those there's been um quite a bit of
interest um so if you have already
applied i'll get back to you
soon but any case come and talk to me um
if you're interested i hope you learn
more economics and if you hope you take
psychological considerations and those
uh economic issues quite seriously so
thank you very much
you